[Music]
i saw this really cute video on youtube
today it shows a tiny newborn giving
what seems to be the finger to her
father this thing's going viral check it
out
hey
lost my papa
did you just flip me off yeah totally
unintentional that's what makes it so
cute actually i believe we have a baby
in our studio audience tonight alan can
we cut to the baby it's completely isn't
that so sweet how cute what a cute
little baby
what a cute little
okay that doesn't look real at all
that's so awful
wouldn't you i think the adult hand
might not be the way to go
anybody else i'm more worried about that
child's malformed hand yeah than i am
about compared to the other one does it
hold up the other hand does the mom look
at see that's they're very different
yeah i think that may help it does that
help it a bit to have the hand up is
that mccann's hand is that your hand
mccann
yeah
i would recognize that bird anywhere you
can put some english on that if we end
up doing it mccann you know what i mean
like you do that kind of wind-up to it
and
yeah
yeah
so stupid all right